someone's asking why do all the planets
orbit in the same direction around the
Sun well this question has been with us
for
centuries and it wasn't until the mid
1700s where an idea was put
forth by llas who suggested that maybe
they formed from a dis of gas that was
swirling around the Sun so whatever you
make out of that disc as you absorb up
the remaining gas whatever you make is
going to have the motion that the
original gas had and that way you get
all the planets orbiting in the same
direction in approximately the same
plane we see the formation of planets
around other stars and they're making
discs so we have independent evidence of
what likely happened at the beginning of
our own solar system so yeah good
question that was